our last question today is from Riley
who said shoot celebrities and athletes
get political or keep it to themselves I
have zero problem with celebrities and
athletes getting political I've said
before my opinion of particular athletes
and celebrities has improved when I find
out about their politics sometimes and
sometimes it has been damaged there are
actors and musicians that I find
completely off-putting now and I won't
go and watch their movies and I won't go
to their shows because I don't like
their politics that being said I'm
absolutely glad to know what the
politics are of athletes are Paula's or
celebrities I sometimes Pat people will
say oh if you're an athlete just play
your sport I don't want to hear about
your your politics why what everybody
who has a public platform has the same
right as anybody else to state their
opinions now there may be repercussions
for that you may get athletes who very
loudly during the course of their games
contests athletic events make their
politics known that could have an effect
on sponsors who say this person's a
little bit risque for us it could be bad
for our brand we're not going to hire
them to do an endorsement it can have a
negative effect on the audience or
whatever but I believe that it is
absolutely fine for celebrities athletes
and musicians to talk about their
politics I'd rather know than not know
and if that makes it so that I no longer
am a fan of someone or want to buy a
ticket to their movie or concert then so
be it I mean I think just people can get
upset about this because they find out
that the celebrities and athletes that
they've been looking up to all these
years have political opinions that don't
necessarily jive with them so they can't
really hold them up on a pedestal
anymore and look to them as role models
because they disagree so fundamentally
on the things that are important to them
so I think most people have given the
option they'd rather just not have their
view of those athletes and celebrities
spoiled in that way by hearing their
political beliefs I've always thought
that it doesn't really make sense
have a professional athlete be a
so-called role model and of all people
Charles Barkley who for a long time was
a Republican although I think he
supported obama i don't really know at
this point it doesn't matter he would
talk about how he doesn't believe that
he should be a role model and I think
he's talked about I thought at one point
maybe he had a gambling problem or
something like that and he said hey I
really shouldn't be a role model and I
think that you're getting at something
which is very interesting which is there
is a different perception of people in
the public eye in terms of their
politics and people immediately comment
about the appropriateness of being
political when your normal day job is X
Y or Z but unless you are in a job where
you are supposed to be a political I
don't know why it's different than
doctors have political views professors
have political views at what point if
you're a not well-known professor versus
a well-known professor is it okay to
express your politics in different
context as long as you're not violating
the duty you have to the students in
your classroom if you're an a semi
professional athlete versus a
professional athlete who's not very well
known versus an all-star athlete does
your right to publicly state your
opinion and take advantage of the public
platform you have change I believe that
the answer is no and there are examples
of athletes that whose politics I
disagree with I still understand their
skill at the sport that they play and I
can watch them and yeah maybe my
enjoyment of it is impacted by the fact
that I think that their politics are
deplorable but at least I have an
ability to separate those things
conceptually and if I no longer have
that ability if I'm deliberately funding
a musician who I find out is a
xenophobic racist right-wing nut I make
the decision to no longer buy a ticket
to their concert and that's a decision
that that I'm grateful for more
information in order to make informed
purchasing decisions I see it the same
way as wanting to know the policies of a
company if I'm going to do business with
them knowing the politics of an
individual if I'm going to support the
work that they do so I think that you
hit on something
very important which is should some of
these individuals be held to a different
or higher standard I would argue the the
answer is no have you had Pat people you
found out Potton athletes celebrities
whatever where when you found out about
their politics you changed your sort of
relationship to them that the fan level
of those individuals not so much because
I think there's a clear difference
between what goes on the field and what
goes off the field so it came out that
Tom Brady and Bill Belichick we don't
know for sure but they're most likely
Trump supporters I mean I have a good
way of changing in my mind how I
appreciate them as athletes and coaches
versus their politics I don't really
care so much about what their political
beliefs are because it just doesn't seem
relevant at all to the work that they do
that I think is an also a key difference
if you're talking about art or music you
may be talking about a different
relationship between politics and the
work then with an athlete and I think
that that's also an interesting
distinction to make all right great
questions this week plenty more coming
up on the bonus show hope you remember
david pakman.com slash membership to
sign up the coupon code I voted 17 is
still available for your use